welcome to the british council learning
hub for secondary plus students okay we
know what you're thinking what is the
learning hub well wonder no more we're
gonna tell you all about it so you can
make the most out of learning english
with the british council wouldn't it be
great if you could feel more confident
to communicate in english the learning
hub is going to help you get there
you'll get to practice your english
before and after class so that you come
to class feeling more prepared in order
to make more progress and that in turn
will help you become more confident
so it works like this at the end of each
class your teacher sets you activities
to do on the learning hub
this could be every week every few weeks
but the point is doing activities on the
learning hub will give you more time to
practice speaking when in class
perfect first you and your parent or
guardian will find all the information
you need to activate your account in
your welcome email once you're logged on
you'll find the module you're working on
press open we'll demonstrate sensational
click on about this module to find out
what you will be learning about in the
sensational module you will learn about
how senses work in animals and humans
click on activities to begin
let's start with section one you can
find vocabulary grammar reading and
listening activities and games in each
section
we'll demonstrate a few for you later in
this video
first we'll show you a few helpful
features such as
your project
let's find it it's in section five
in each module you'll work on a
real-life project with your classmates
for example in sensational you'll create
a show board to present at a science
fair
the projects are designed to improve not
only your english skills but also life
skills such as team working and
creativity and study skills to help you
in school and prepare for university
now let's go to the resources section
click on open document to view the
course magazine you will use in class
we'll now show you how to upload a
written assignment for your teacher to
review
go to activities section 1
to upload your written work click choose
file
and select the document from your
computer
then click submit
an exciting part of the learning hub is
being able to track your progress
the progress dashboard is found in the
about this module section
now let's take a closer look at the
activities that will help you prepare
for class and work towards your end of
module project
we'll demonstrate a few for you section
one and the first activity focuses on
improving your reading skills
read the blog my life as a deaf team
then answer true or false questions on
what you've just read
[Music]
click finish to check the ones you've
got correct
i got four out of six
not bad
let's use verbs to talk about the five
senses and complete these sentences
the words to choose from are in this box
let's do the first sentence
click on the empty space in the sentence
and then on the word that you want to go
there
let's go to the next one
if you change your mind click on the box
again and the word will go back up
once complete click finish and you'll
see what answers you got correct
you can also click on the speakerphone
icon to listen to the sentences
let's go to section two
we'll do an exercise that improves your
listening skills we'll play a short clip
of the interview listen for the answers
to these sentences
so when you're ready click play
hi alex
so
you're here today to tell us about what
it's like to be colorblind
now choose the correct answer
we'll only show you one today
once you're happy with your answers
click finish
let's go to section four and do the
reading exercise to learn some new words
read this article about animals and
natural disasters
your task is to complete the sentences
type one word in each space
disasters
indonesia
and so on
then click finish to check your answers
don't worry if you get any wrong you can
try again and that's it friends come and
join us on the learning hub we're with
you every step of the way